how did you get over that that breaking
point I guess I didn't I quit
like a months ago I just quit that was
the American expression like the straw
that broke the camel's back
[Music]
in some ways this 2-minute theme
encapsulates the 500 hours I spent with
oblivion Adventure Wonder terror
friendship beauty I can hear it all in
this song even listening to it now I'm
transported back to a time when things
were simpler a time when it was easier
for me to get lost in a game like the
Elder Scrolls 4
[Music]
despite my fond memories for oblivion
it's a flawed game it suffers from
Bethesda's iconic bugginess it looked in
felt generic especially off the back of
Morrowind and the generated aspects of
the map felt at odds with a previously
established lore so in 2016 when I heard
there was a mod project in the works to
recreate the Elder Scrolls for oblivion
and Skyrim I was ecstatic sky Bolivian
is part of the tes renewal project which
is a volunteer project that aims to
recreate oblivion and morrowind for a
new generation sky Bolivian is exactly
what you'd expect based on the name
oblivion recreated in sky arms improved
engine a team of roughly 100 volunteers
are painstakingly rebuilding Serie del
oblivion setting from scratch all of
oblivion x' quests side quests guild
quests and main quests will be playable
from start to finish all the cities are
being redesigned with a fresh coat of
paint the NPCs are getting much-needed
facelifts and the armor sets in clothing
are getting reworked although the quests
will be the same sky bolivian is shaping
up to be more of a reimagining than a
recreation eager to learn more about the
project I reached out to project leading
creative director Kyle rebel I've been
wanting games for quite a while at least
a few years before oblivion was released
at that time it was mostly Maus like
counter-strike you know the mapping
tools had so come out for that game and
I started to become familiar ground for
my friends and I with Oblivion's release
the the modding addiction kind of picked
up speed I don't know how much of
Oblivion you remember but the whole map
looked more or less the same green grass
stone roads a couple of rocks scattered
around and lots of hills there wasn't a
ton of diversity or character even Bruma
felt kind of generic despite being right
on the border of Skyrim that's one of
many things sky oblivion aims to fix
well I think like you said that the
biggest improvement or the the biggest
content piece of concept we're adding is
a world map that's been recreated almost
from scratch to be much more diverse in
the lore seer Dale is supposed to be a
lush and diverse province while Oblivion
does do some things to give these areas
unique characteristics as a whole they
all kind of blend
gather an even better example to be
Blackwood's which is supposed to be a
swamp or a marsh like area but in
Oblivion instead of it being very wet
very flat and very Marsh like it uses
those same automatically generated Hills
everywhere which kind of ruins the
diversion that the game could have had
like every every biome should have felt
a lot more unique than it did so that's
something that we can put our own spin
on the team can also use the new
environments to build off pre-existing
stories and quests there's a big ayleid
ruin that's been taken over by
necromancer's and the weld is a
beautiful colorful biome in serial and
what we actually did was around the the
a lead ruin we replaced some of the very
big lush trees that we had placed
originally with dead versions so it's
kind of like an indication that
something is is not really right because
there's barely a single dead tree in in
the entire region but for some reason
around this early ruin there's like six
or eight all near the the entrance of
the ruin which is kind of like an
indication that something might be amiss
so stuff like that is a really neat way
of using the world around you to tell a
story and sky Bolivians goal of
introducing diversity into this story
and lore isn't limited to the world
oblivion had a lot of unique or a lot of
quest rewards like there's a lot of
quests where you can get a sword a
helmet a shield or whatever and
sometimes these are supposed to be
family heirlooms and in sakai bolivian
we actually took the time to create a
unique asset for those so for instance
in the arena quest line you kill a
keshite i think who is wielding a dagger
and that dagger has a name and it's
supposed to be a very it's a piece of
craftsmanship
but when you you kill the guy it's it's
just like an elven dagger I think
nothing special so what we did is we
based on the name that it had we created
the concept and there's not like an
actual unique dagger in the game that
you can take as a reward for killing him
now if you played oblivion that may have
set off a red flag but don't worry just
like in Oblivion Kyle assured me that
you won't be able to loot corpses in the
arena this battle is an exception
despite these changes Oblivion's quest
story dialogue and characters will
remain the same the mod itself won't
have voice acting but according to Kyle
it will be very easy for users to import
oblivion voice lines into Skype live Ian
this means hopefully with a few clicks
you can hear Patrick Stewart and Sean
Bean reprised their roles find him and
close shut the jaws of oblivion oh and
you'll be able to hear this again then
pay with your blood in this by Azura by
Hosoda by assume it's the Grand Champion
I can't believe it's you standing here
next to me if you follow large-scale mod
projects you might have heard of Kyle
rebel or his youtube channel rebels eyes
most of sky Bolivians preview content is
housed on his channel and he manages PR
for the project but he wasn't always
leading the charge in fact one of his
first tasks was to remake every single
oblivion NPC in Skyrim's Creation Kit
thank you kind sir oh yeah it was a
nightmare and the funniest thing is that
this task was incredibly intimidating
because you have to set up like a
pipeline you have to create a kind of a
management system that I had never done
before I mean this was all with people
who you only talk to online we didn't
have this discord yet so daily or weekly
cost wasn't a thing just private
messages and setting all that up was a
complete nightmare and yeah we had to go
through hundreds of characters and
recreate them by hands and you know that
was just a first step in what would
later become a much much bigger project
with a lot more challenging tasks at
hands you know
while he had a hand in getting the
project off the ground he credits a lot
of the work to Z lava Norman they
created many of the tools needed to prep
and convert oblivion assets to Skyrim
without these tools there would be no
sky bolivian at least in its current
form from there the team slowly expanded
as it expanded Kyle had to learn how to
manage and direct a team and very
quickly I figured out that for any any
project or any game that wants to be
successful you you really need a few
people at the helm like you can't have
four different artists work on four
different weapon sets and expect them to
turn out in the way that they all look
like they belong in the same game or
let's say you have four people make four
different houses there's no way you can
build a city out of those houses because
they will be completely different like
they will be using different textures
materials shapes so as a creative
director it's kind of my job to make
sure that everything plays together
nicely
not only is it difficult to manage a
team of this size but you also have to
consider that this is a volunteer
project Kyle was very clear that at the
end of the day this shouldn't feel like
work it should be a collective creative
outlet if you have to go to work you
have to go to school if you're simply
beat and you can get yourself to you
know sit behind a computer all day
that's fine I mean it's a volunteer
project I'm not going to force anyone to
do anything I appreciate every second
that the guys and girls give us and I
can't and I won't ask for any more than
that and because sky' Bolivian at its
core is a volunteer project he also
keeps money out of the equation as often
as possible
occasionally Kyle and his team will have
to pay for small service fees in order
to keep the project running when those
fees build up him and his team put
together a small fundraiser and if
anyone donates more than a few bucks
they'll usually return the money to the
original donor turns out that we have to
pay for our websites in two days we
thought we had until January 8th I think
turns out it's December 8th and I didn't
want to ask our development team for
money
because well I mean they've been you
know giving us all their time already
and I figured that last year we raised
enough money to pay for the website
relatively quickly so we would do that
again and any donations not any high
donations I'm just gonna refund I I
really do not want people to donate
anything over five dollars or euros or
pounds like the reason why I simply
refused to set up a patreon for the
skate oblivion project is because I have
no idea how the hell or how we would
decide who gets how much do we pay
people based on the amount of hours they
put in do we pay people based on how
critical their work is because for
instance we have only three guys working
on the quests and if any of those guys
drop out worth so do I use 50% of the
budget just to keep those guys in a team
or do I use it to pay the one landscape
or that has done half the map on his own
those are decisions that I think it's is
it's gonna cause nothing but trouble in
the long run
[Music]
however many of the challenges Kyle has
faced over the years aren't solely due
to the mod itself he's received death
threats as property has been stolen and
he's endured tragedy you really need to
think skin to work on something like
this when people can just contact you
for the Internet's like I if I've had
death threats pretty much since 2016 or
people wishing me the worst kind of
fates because of just how you're
choosing to recreate this not because of
the way you're recreating it but because
the the build is internal you have to
you have to work on a project get access
to the build we can distribute Calligan
in its current form because it's still
using placeholder assets from oblivion
and we have an understanding with
Bethesda that's whatever we do we cannot
ship our mod with assets that don't
belong to us that's that's the only
thing they they they told us not to do
so of course we respect that and because
because of that that the the project
stays internal a while ago for instance
at a ridiculous time someone started
attacking me in the the public discord
and telling me to go myself that that I
should die and also like just horrible
stuff about my partner who had only
passed away like maybe six months prior
Jesus said that is that's that's [ __ ]
up that's really messed up [ __ ] you have
to you know you really need some thick
skin to be able to actually read that
delete it and banned that person because
that you know that's that's really
inhumane and that's that's really
unfortunate side of this project
[Music]
while this story is unique to Kyle being
thrown into the public eye for better or
worse is a possible outcome for efforts
like these this kind of behavior is
almost to be expected when it comes to
projects being developed by an
experienced studio backed by
corporations but when the project at
hand is being created by fans for free
and their spare time purely because they
love it and want to breathe new life
into a beloved game this kind of
behavior is even more reprehensible but
it's important to note that these people
are the exception not the standard and
Kyle was quick to point out that 99% of
the people following the project are
positive and supportive to the cause
that being said it can be really hard to
ignore the hate eventually that
negativity will pile up you know luckily
there's way more people that support you
and wish you all the best but that's
something that at times can be really
challenging I have actually i I've had a
bit of a mental breakdown like a month
ago firstly because of the stress and
because people seem to think that you're
holding back on them or out you're
rolling out on them for over on purpose
which is not always nice so yeah that's
that's a really big challenge like you
have to be able to deal with that and
especially when you work on this for
years
you know you might run into a breaking
point you know and that's
yeah how did you get over that that that
breaking point I guess I didn't I quit
like a month ago I just quit yeah I that
there was it was like the kind of most
American expression like the straw that
broke the camel's back a series of
events of course at the last year year
and a half you know I haven't made my
life easy and that the project is a way
to kind of keep myself occupied and and
then at some point one of the the
developers and why should one of my
friends now send me his old graphics
cards which was insane for my birthday
this I was it was amazing and I got the
Box today and I found the bag and it's
empty
I'm just so I'm so tired I'm so tired I
have the worst year of my life and ends
my birthday it sucks because she isn't
there and the friend is nice enough to
send me something like this like you
[ __ ] this thing was I think it's still
400 euros insane and it gets being
stolen and that was like for me I took
it as a sign from the universe to go my
stuff you know like that was just that
was it I wasn't able to deal with that
[ __ ] anymore so I just quit I told the
guys you know I even need a break or I'm
just I might come back in a week I might
come back in two weeks we'll see what
happens and I just I left
fortunately Kyle did find his way back
to sky bolivian and his team put
together a fundraiser to get him a new
graphics card despite these frustrations
it's clear that sky bolivian is a
dominant and important part of Kyle's
life breaks and vacations are healthy
even for something you do for fun in
your free time but it sounds like Kyle
and his team are hell-bent on finishing
this project my personal motivation is a
bit more simple than that of course I
want people to play the mods but
personally what I take out of this
project because obviously we're not
making any money off of it is it's just
fun there's a there's a very good chance
that I will never get a job in the
gaming industry so the way I see it is
that if I can
leave a lasting impression on this world
through Skype live Ian and this is my
one chance to do it then I will happily
put in all my time and effort that I
have where they can spare I've met a lot
of great people and that's great and
that's that's enough for me and besides
that like I said I have a partner or I
had a partner who was a big fan of this
project and who loved that I worked on
it so you know even for her sake I just
I want to get this done I want people to
enjoy this and at the end of the day I
want to look back at my time working
this project and just feel like what we
did you know I had a good impression in
the world we had a positive impression I
want to be proud of myself I'm gonna be
proud of the people that I work with I
think that's really important we only
have one life you know so might as well
spend it doing something that's I enjoy
[Music]